the coronavirus has hit all European
countries and it has put all our health
systems under pressure but some
countries in particular Italy and Spain
have been hit earlier and much harder
than others support from the European
Union and from other EU countries is
crucial to help them cope with the
pandemic our European solidarity can
save lives what hospitals in these
countries need most are respiratory
ventilators I'm grateful to Denmark
which will send ventilators and I'm
mobile field hospital to Italy it comes
just days after teams of European
doctors and nurses from Romania and no
way were deployed to Italy through the
European Union civil protection
mechanism further support will come from
the European Union we are creating a
strategic reserve of ventilators to send
them to the countries that need the most
Romania has offered to be the first
country to host this EU reserve the
first 150 ventilators paid by the
European Union budget iron production
and will be dispatched to the countries
most in need immediately we're also
buying together through joint
procurement ventilators as well as
protective equipment such as masks in
this unprecedented crisis we are
stronger together in the European Union